when i tell people that i'm a wrestler
they don't really believe me at first i
don't know what image they have in their
head of what a wrestler should look like
especially when i say i'm the super
heavy weight for women's wrestling and
they're like you wrestle like you're
you're kind of too pretty to wrestle and
it's always interesting to me because
i'm like what did you expect
my name is adeline gray i'm a three-time
world champion ranked number one in the
world been undefeated for two and a half
years and i'm going to compete in the
rio olympic games in august
i never really considered the olympics
as an option for me when i was younger
kid and it's something that i don't
think enough girls have an opportunity
to dream about
i want to redefine feminine to some
extent and and to have people challenge
the way they look at the word strong and
not just see a boy that pops into your
head
i started wrestling boys when i was six
years old and i wrestled boys all the
way through high school
and i think i earned a lot of respect
from a lot of the the teammates out
there who did lose to me or maybe beat
me and i got to train with the best guys
in the world and they made me tougher
they made me work for every single point
i had to wrestle with and and they made
it so that i could be a champion on the
women's level now
we teach girls to be perfect and boys to
take risks i need to take risks that i
am a confident and strong female who
knows that i'm great at wrestling i'm
still struggling with that concept that
i'm worried about not being perfect when
i step on the mat
i have to step on that mat and make sure
that i work every single moment to win
an olympic gold medal
i want young girls to be able to look at
that my situation and be able to dream
about it
i'm excited for that moment to have my
flag risen and and be able to know that
i'm going to hold a gold medal around my
neck
truck
i think the typical fencer
looks nerdy predominantly
caucasian
so i think i'm on the opposite spectrum
of what a fencer
looks like acts like and
is in person
i'm watching watson i'm a two-time
olympian and world champion
as a troubled nine and off-road i had to
do a lot of extracurricular activities
that was offered in my
middle school so i first picked up a
foil which is what they like to call a
sword
i just immediately fell off with it
i didn't think it would take me this far
but uh i've been rolling with it ever
since
people should know that fencing is
it's a combat sport they think it's
super
fluffy and all this but no it's really
intimate
you can literally hear them breathe you
can see their eyes you really see if
someone's scared if someone has no
emotions and that's so cool about the
sport is you can really gauge your
opponent emotionally which i don't think
you can in many sports
well i think the fencing community
they've embraced me but then you have
people obviously who are older who want
to see the sport the same
people have always said like you won't
win this competition you want make a
national team you won't
ever you know make an olympic team you
know you want free world champion i'm
gonna win just
make you eat your work
hate us your motivators it just comes
with territory
the first time i ever qualify for
olympics it's just the most incredible
feeling because all that hard work pays
off because
0.11 of the publisher goes to the
olympics
i think being outsider just you have
more drive than everyone else because
you want to prove you're wrong
i broke my neck
i beat cancer and i'm going to rio
this is the first time that women's
rugby will be in the olympics i'm
jillian potter and i play rugby for team
usa
rugby in particular is a very good life
lessons teacher so when you get tackled
you have to get back up no matter how
hard it is i'm going to get up
i broke my neck playing rugby in 2010.
but when i was hit
i felt and i heard just pop pop pop pop
and i knew immediately something was
wrong
when the doctors came in and told me i
might not ever be able to play rugby
again i like tried to silently cry for a
while
i went through this like period of
allowing myself to to be upset and then
being like get it together jillian like
you can be strong in this moment there
was about a year between when i broke my
neck and when i was able to get back on
the field with my team and then in june
of 2014 i was diagnosed with a very rare
soft tissue cancer i had chemo and
radiation for seven months and i lost
about 20 pounds
throughout the treatment i was actually
able to work out and that was something
that i was pretty adamant about
thankfully the chemotherapy worked and
i'm cancer-free but it could have easily
turned the other way and i don't think
i could even imagine what that would be
like but i would hope that i would still
have that attitude of never giving up
and rugby was instrumental in getting me
back to where i am today the rugby
community it really helped me
stay positive and keep working out keep
that fire to say i'm going to be back
and i'm going to be ready for real
are two of the ten refugees selected to
be a part of the first olympic refugee
team
they will be competing in judo
they both fled conflict in the
democratic republic of congo and in the
2016 olympics we'll compete without a
country
um
both sought asylum in brazil during the
judo world championships in 2013.
they haven't seen their family since
family
by competing in the olympics they are
bringing their story to a global
audience
um
so
we will see a transgender olympian in my
lifetime someone who is out and
authentic with their identity and still
competing in sports at a high level
because now it's possible
my name is chris mosier and i'm the
first transgender man to make a men's us
national team
my sport is sprint duathlon and duathlon
is run bike run
when i first started competing after
transition no one really thought that i
would do well everyone pretty much just
wrote me off because they looked at me
and thought oh he's a trans guy there's
no way that he can compete against men
hearing people say that really motivated
me to work harder to learn more to be
more dedicated to my training
and try to be the strongest competitor
that i could be
even though i made team usa i was
ineligible to compete at the world level
because of the international olympic
committee policy which stated
transgender athletes needed to have a
full lower surgery performed in order to
qualify
adding an extra body part is not going
to make me a faster runner or a stronger
cyclist
they just needed an athlete with a name
and a face
someone who was actually being impacted
by this policy to look at it and to say
this isn't right the international
olympic committee changed their policy
for transgender athletes and no longer
have the same restrictions they had
before
i was so thrilled when the policy was
changed for myself but i was even
happier that the policy has now changed
for everybody who comes after me i will
not be competing in rio because duathlon
is not an olympic sport but i am so
excited to someday see a transgender
olympian compete on behalf of our
country what used to be the ceiling is
now the floor
you